it's the only workplace the only
occupation we're by and large you are
not paid promoted recognized measured in
any way having to do with your
performance only having to do with how
long you've been breathing I am Nick
Gillespie with Reason TV and today we're
talking with Steven Brill the author of
class warfare the creator of American
Lawyer content court TV and your most
recent foray into alternative media as
well Steve Brill thanks for talking to
us happy to do it
what's the rubber room and its
significance to your critique of the
educational establishment the rubber
room was how I got into this and started
thinking about this as a journalist and
it's really the tip of the iceberg these
were rooms set up in New York formerly
called the temporary relocation Center
or something sort of Kremlin s like that
where the rare rare rare teacher among
the 75 or 80 thousand public school
teachers in New York who were actually
identified as being the worst of the
worst of the worst just utterly
incompetent or abusive to students
sometimes even they'd been charged with
crimes so under the Union contract they
were entitled to long arbitration
hearings as part of their tenure
protection and the arbiters would have
to be approved every year by the
teachers union and the contract said
that they could only hold hearings on
each case once or twice during a month
long story short these hearings dragged
on longer than the OJ Simpson trial
invariably resulted in some kind of
compromise of the teachers being may
actually put back in the classroom after
they got this three or four or five year
rest in the rubber and that's where
they're just collecting their full pay
and collect in full pay and accruing
pension benefits you've said that you
read the union contract you know which
is hundreds of thousands of millions of
words long for fun what's you know what
are some of the egregious examples that
you see that are carved out there well
in Wisconsin taxpayers of Wisconsin pay
teachers to go to the
regional and state union conventions in
New York the principle is not allowed to
comment on the form or format of a
teacher's lesson plan the day is
scripted out for a teacher down to I'm
not making this up the last 30 seconds
typically it's a 35 or 36 week school
year why god only knows
and in that 35 or 36 weeks
the typical union contract for teachers
is they're entitled to 11 to 14 sick and
personal days off do the math that's
basically a day off every three weeks
it's the only workplace the only
occupation we're by and large you are
not paid promoted recognized measured in
any way having to do with your
performance only having to do with how
long you've been breathing are these
union contracts and problems do those
transfer the suburbs I mean you talked
about larger urban areas outside of that
are the schools pretty good some of them
are good but but in the suburbs the
union contracts are typically not as
strong and the parents are stronger the
school systems are smaller which which
creates its own set of economic problems
with you know little bureaucratic tiny
little school systems but it's not the
same kind of problem and there's
competition outside the cities because
there are enough well-to-do parents and
the suburbs that they can look at
private schools the change that has
spurred the reform that I write about in
this book one of the key changes is the
growth of charter schools thousands of
charter schools some of them 20% 30% are
really well run really well supervised
by the school districts and what happens
they prove that demography doesn't have
to be destiny there is a building that I
write about in this book in Harlem where
half of the building is a charter school
which is a public school taxpayers pay
for it's free the other half is a
conventional public school and the
charter school the kids are performing
on their exams at a level equivalent to
the schools
in Scarsdale which is very wealthy New
York suburb on the conventional side on
the public school side the kids are
performing unfortunately the way the
stereotype would have you expect the
kids from impoverished sometimes broken
homes the calls are from saying this
it's the same creating an insulin one
system produces South Korea one produces
it's like you know when you fly over
Korea you don't see the lights on in the
north you see all the lights on
except it's even more significant than
that because it's often you know there
are siblings on two sides of the
building so the parents know now the the
significance of that is in Harlem as in
New Orleans when you start to have
twenty five thirty five percent of the
school children in high-performing
charter schools then there's competition
all the parents know it the parents
demand that the politicians give them
that kind of school choice and that's
what's really frightening to the keepers
of the status quo it's one thing to have
a monopoly where everything is really
terrible but there's nothing to compare
to and even if you could compare it
there's not anything you can do about it
talk about the role of Technology I mean
you have created time and again new ways
of delivering you know media content of
opening up areas of discourse is
technology the game-changer in education
is it actually a distraction is the idea
of putting a computer in front of every
kid a waste of time how is technology
ultra I don't I don't claim to know
enough about it in terms of cognitive
skills and what works and doesn't work
but I have seen teachers that some of
the really well-run charter schools be
able to look at homework and give
instant feedback on a tablet back to the
kids back to their parents back to the
teachers you know supervisor so the
supervisor can see that di't that the
teachers providing that feedback just
little things like that
the other real potential breakthrough is
in distance learning if you have you
know high schoolers who want to take
advanced subjects but there's just not
enough you know critical mass in that
high school maybe it's a rural high
school
they can they can take that course
online interestingly again the forces of
the status quo conspire against that the
way they can spire against the
marketplace of choice there are
provisions in the union contracts in New
York for example that require that a
student I'm going to paraphrase this a
student can't get credit for being in a
classroom in learning unless there is a
teacher physically present in that
classroom which is just crazy
for reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie we've
been talking with Steven Brill author of
class warfare thank you thank you